[Musique]
et de nouveau à cause d'un nom un nom
sur un visage un visage sur l'accord cam
a été la proie un tourbillon pas tout de
suite à l'aérodrome de nice il n'y avait
guère connu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais dès que l'on en a su davantage cela
change
claudia cardinale c'est ce que l'on peut
voir de plus joli en ce moment sur la
croisette de plus vivant de plus heureux
de vivre jugé compliqué
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et contrairement à ce que vous pourriez
supposé toutes ces images sont doués de
la parole il semble que tout au cinéma
soit fixé une fois pour toutes les
grandes vedettes sont de grandes
vedettes depuis de nombreuses années
voire même quelquefois depuis avant
guerre quant aux nouvelles à peine à
prendre tout leur nom qu'elle devienne
célèbre et à peine sont elles célèbrent
qu'on ne sait plus comment il s'appelle
heureusement ou voilà claudia cardinale
vous êtes jeune votre carrière est
assuré et par dessus le marché
vous nous faites un cadeau inestimable
vous parler français le oui je suis né à
tunis et j'ai fait mes études en france
est invitée à la maison je parle
français mais je suis italienne il n'y a
pas très longtemps que vous êtes
endettés à vie quand même nom exactement
trois heures quand j'ai commencé avec le
pigeon mais vous êtes venu on est allé
vous avez fait le cas comment est ce que
doit être un pigeon
oh ça a été très compliqué parce que je
n'ai pas du tout envie de faire du
cinéma et c'était bien malgré moi mais
je suis contente mais pourquoi les
réponses à des cinémas ce que j'y
pensais pas gelé en classe une vie
contenant différentes mais on m'a dit
vous allez faire concours de beauté oui
c'est vrai j'étais là viendrait pas
envie de faire du cinéma
non c'était pour le voyage à c'était
pour le voyage lui festival de venise
là c'est très curieux c'est que les
concours de beauté chez nous ça sert
strictement à rien le coni ta vie je ne
sais pas pourquoi vous avez besoin des
prix de beauté forme nettement du cinéma
je me sens exactement le contraire
d'ailleurs annoncé mardi soir depuis
vous avez fait nombreux films effet le
pigeon qui ont beaucoup aimé
bref et combien de films en tout
quatorze 14 mai trois ans et ici vous
arrivez à cannes
non seulement avec un film avec deux
avoue ça doit représenter presque tout
le cinéma italien à cannes une double
hauteur w oui car ce film
le premier qui sera présenté ce soir la
viaccia de bolognini avec jean paul
belmondo la voiture la viaccia c'est le
mauvais chemin et le deuxième la fille à
la valise de dures ligne
avec perrin est encore très jeune ma
faim le fait même que vous ayez déjà
fait autant film prouve que vous devez
avoir certaines idées sur la façon de
mener votre vie comment est ce que vous
entendez conduit à votre carrière
surtout ne pas suivre une route par
exemple ou être dramatiques ou être
comique mais j'aime faire tout oui on
dirait d'ailleurs que vous n'avez
absolument peur de devenir un personnage
les images que nous avons vues de leurs
livres qui vous est consacré sur toutes
différentes
je préfère pourquoi votre personnage ne
vous plaît pas non c'est pas ça mais
elle n'en sait pas savais pas ce que
j'aime faire tout ce que c'est plus
intéressant est ce que vous trouvez
normal succès que peut avoir une actrice
ça je ne sais pas je suis toujours très
étonnée je ne sais pas quand vous pensez
par exemple aux français avant qu'on ne
connaît pas ce que c'est normal qu'on
demande tellement d'autographes genre et
uniquement parce qu'ils font et et a
traditionnellement oui peut-être mais
c'est une chose tellement c'est pas
croyable d'être connus comme ça lance
dans le cinéma alors que d'autres
saveurs mais c'est comme ça si la main
vous connaissez plus ça vous fait de la
peine comment si on vous oubliez de
miles on mélange bien sûr ça ferait de
la peine mais j'essaierai de faire
quelque chose d'autre
je regarde très naturellement qu'est ce
que vous feriez par exemple il ya
beaucoup de chose j'aimerais par exemple
m'occuper d'eux de mode ou ou alors
voyage n ont rien fait est ce qu'il vous
arrive de suivre les conseils quand vous
donne oui oui j'écoute ma femme c'est un
peu ma tête
est-ce que vous suivre est ce que vous y
voyez par exemple conseils que je vais
vous donner quel surtout reste toujours
comme aux actes merci
[Musique]